cet été sera le dernier pour le club de
golf les légendes situé dans le quartier
saint luc à saint jean sur richelieu le
terrain fermera ses portes à la fin de
la saison
après 45 ans d'existence les
propriétaires veulent utiliser le
terrain pour faire du développement
immobilier
le golf est moins payant qu'avant la
relève et paula les gens ont d'autres
intérêts par rapport à des activités de
récréation aux sportives dans bien des
situations et c'est le code un code est
d'aider les gens il faut poursuivre
comme ça encore par dix ans le projet
prévoit la construction d'environ 500
unités d'habitation et la création d'un
parc nature de presque 15 hectares mais
le projet suscite de l'inquiétude chez
les riverains qui se sont regroupés au
sein de la coalition saint luc bon
nombre d'entre eux s'opposent au
changement de zonage nécessaire pour
transformer le golf en secteur
résidentiel
il ya une acceptabilité sociale qui doit
être prise en considération et on a
l'impression que elle n'est pas là du
tout vous voyez c'est extraordinaire on
est des arbres que ne peut que d'enlever
d'armature de l'irak sont très vieux
si vous mettez de maison qui sait où les
arbres c'est un élu pour apaiser la
contestation les promoteurs ont organisé
leur propre consultation publique avec
le concours d'une firme de communication
c'est un début une amorce de dialogue
maintenant il faut le poursuivre mais il
n'ya pas que le club des légendes
il ya aussi l'ancien golf des boisés de
la mairie située tout près ce terrain a
été racheté il ya dix ans par les
baillargeaux une famille d'industriels
connu à saint jean sur richelieu
elle aussi espèrent un changement de
zonage une demande a été faite plus tôt
cette année et dans un document de cour
déposé le mois dernier les baillargeon
prie le tribunal d'ordonner à la
municipalité de traiter cette demande
immédiatement le porte-parole de la
coalition saint-luc souhaite que ses
demandes de changements tournage soit
rejetée il fait valoir que les golfs et
des boisés qui les entourent ont une
certaine valeur écologique
évitez les îlots de chaleur que la
nature puisse reprendre ses droits
juste en arrière de moi on a quelques
familles de chevreuil qui sont venus
s'installer on a des rapports c'est un
milieu qui est vraiment fantastique pour
tout ce côté là qu'on a besoin milieu
urbain ces préoccupations sont partagé
par le maire alain laplante qui se pose
lui aussi à ses projets immobiliers
il propose plutôt de racheter les
terrains mais à la valeur du rôle
d'évaluation municipale et non à la
valeur spéculative d'un projet
domiciliaire
évidemment si nous changeons l'âge la
valeur de ce terrain là explosé on parle
de dizaines de dizaines de millions de
dollars
donc elle est là l'enjeu donc 700
entente sur le prix lui imagine que les
citoyens ne sont peut-être pas lésiné
pas dit quelle est la plante encore
maire dans six mois
majoritaires au conseil de ville son
mandat a été mouvementée en 2019
il a même été suspendu trois mois pour
une série de manquements éthiques
andré bouchard se présente contre lui
aux élections c'est ex présidente de la
commission scolaire des hautes rivières
a réuni de nombreux élus autour d'elle
son équipe est ouverte au développement
immobilier mais pas à n'importe quel
prix
mais j'aimerais vraiment que les
citoyens soient en amont des projets pop
quand l'école qu'on essaie de rentrer
dans la gorge des projets si elle est
élue de nouvelles consultations
publiques seront organisées ici les
riverains en font la demande
un référendum sera tenu l'avenir des
golfs suscite le débat depuis plusieurs
années à saint jean sur richelieu
mais ce n'est pas la seule municipalité
à vivre une telle situation depuis 2006
12 des 72 du grand montréal ont fermé
leurs portes pour laisser place en tout
ou en partie à des projets de
développement immobilier
ici jérôme l'abbé radio canada saint
jean sur richelieu